Peter Weber's mom is telling the haters
to stop madness is a sweet girl lovely
girl that had a an is an angel on earth
and I want him to make the right choice
trolls came after mama barb after she
said all of that during night one of the
bachelor finale but barb
she isn't fazed by the hate on Tuesday
she shared this clip of her and some
friends dancing to stop in the name of
love before you when one band urged
critics to leave the bachelors mom alone
barb chimed in writing I ignore all the
negatives what type of woman would you
describe that Peter should get
adventurous spontaneous someone sweet
with a great heart as well that's the
most important thing for a man well
Barb's post was in response to all the
negativity that followed night one when
she straight up said she preferred
Hannah an over Madison crew it you
deserve the best a mother's intuition is
never wrong barb just may have faced
even more backlash after Tuesday night's
episode after Peter ended his engagement
to Hannah Anne I'm sorry
and reunited live with Madison during
part two of the finale how does it feel
to see Peter again barb hardcore slammed
Madison for showing up three hours late
to their meeting in Australia when she
did come in the whole family you know we
didn't get an apology from her and when
I proceeded to ask her if she was madly
in love with my son she said no and that
she would not accept a proposal in four
days and as a mother that you know it
wasn't what we were expecting protected
mama bear I'm not mad at it barb I'm not
a mom so like I don't know what it's
like you know to have to have a son to
have kids I know that I have love and
respect for Peter therefore I have love
and respect for Peters family and I will
never like say a negative word about
anyone or anything
well the Twitterverse lit up like a
freaking Christmas tree and most people
seem to be standing strong on team
Madison one fan wrote quote the nerf
barb had to mistreat Maddie like that
and to humiliate her in front of
national TV I've seriously had enough of
barb for today so they just cancelled
barb anyway
former Bachelorette Jo Jo Fletcher
tweeted quote oh hell barb what is even
happening right now and another person
dropped the mic writing when we all
thought the villain was Victoria F but
it really was barb Weber like I get it
because like literally they feel sick
crank I'm like god oh damn
them fighting words and despite all the
not so nice chatter about barb
Peter said on Tuesday's episode that he
knows his mom was only coming from a
place of love I know that their biggest
worry and their biggest concern was just
that you weren't there with me the way I
was there with you I can tell you guys
that I know how she feels for me and I
know how I feel for her
back in February pilot Pete T's the
bombshell ending to et I am very very
close to my family and I value their
opinion and that was a that was a really
tough over free that was a brutal and
there's the last thing I needed to hear
in that moment absolutely last I've been
through so much up to that point it was
tough well that's it for today
stick with ET for all things bachelor
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens and
I'll see you soon
[Music]